[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
discuter échanger et débattre sur des
sujets d'actualité alors halliche à 14
ans est morte noyée dans la seine lundi
8 mars
un drame sur fond de rivalités et de
harcèlement sur les réseaux sociaux
ce lundi 15 mars un jeune garçon de 11
ans se défenestre après une punition
pour harcèlement deux actualités qui
remettent sous le feu des projecteurs la
question du harcèlement scolaire
alors où en est-on dans la lutte contre
ce fait de société
c'est la thématique que nous allons
aborder dans les prochaines minutes avec
nos trois invités sébastin ta sébastien
tu avais un bon soir soir vous êtes
proviseur vie scolaire et référent
départemental harcèlement pour
l'académie de versailles
isabelle duclos bonsoir en chemin vous
êtes responsable de l'école des parents
de guyancourt et blanc d'une ferreira
bonsoir pourquoi vous êtes élève de bts
au lycée basque en devant le levier est
ambassadrice lycéenne alors j'ai débuté
cette émission avec deux drames l'un a
eu lieu dans l'académie de versailles
sébastien taverne cela armes et le
harcèlement en lumière et j'imagine que
ça fait aussi beaucoup à réfléchir
oui malheureusement le drame qu'a vécu
argenteuil ces derniers jours vient
remettre la thématique du harcèlement en
lumière médiatique mais c'est pas un
sujet qui est dans l'ombre des
préoccupations de l'éducation nationale
on
chaque jour on travaille sur la
thématique avec l'ensemble des
partenaires
les parents les forces de l'ordre les
élèves que blandine représente ce soir
et cdc des moments qui font que ça nous
rappelle que la mobilisation elle et
elle est nécessaire et doit être
quotidienne et est renforcée à chaque
instant alors en 2015 justement le
ministère d'éducation généralise la
formation d'ambassadeur lycéens dans un
premier temps il travaille contre le
harcèlement et le cyber harcèlement
blandine ferreira vous est ambassadrice
depuis trois ans qu'est ce qui vous a
motivé à vous engager sur la question du
harcèlement
ce qui m'amuse c'est tout simplement le
fait que j'ai été victime de harcèlement
scolaire en primaire et je veux aider
les autres pour pas qu'il fasse la même
chose les mêmes erreurs c'est à dire
rester sous le silence parce que
vraiment la solution
et je trouve qu'on le dit pas assez
c'est vraiment d'en parler c'est comme
ça qu'on se sort de ce phénomène de
harcèlement alors les communes se
mobilisent aussi contre ce phénomène on
a entendu l'éducation nationale et les
jeunes à conflans sainte honorine la
ville a mis en place un plan de lutte
ces écoles élémentaires plus de 2000
enfants sont concernés
on écoute les précisions de laurent
brosse le maire de la commune il était
l'invité d'eléonore sinoquet le sur
l'ordre du cetud ce week-end du 12 mars
dernier
concrètement on l'a souvent articulé
autour de trois axes le premier as c'est
informer et sensibiliser le deuxième axe
c'est un axe qui est plus un axe pour
former le troisième race c'est prévenir
et gien le projet toujours de détendre
ce sionisme qu'il faut au collège et au
lycée
en réalité je suis en pleine
concertation en ce moment avec
l'éducation nationale avec l'association
sportive également sur le plan d'action
pour la jeunesse et la citoyenneté est
donc ce plan inclut un volet de lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire dans les
collèges et les lycées
c'est un plan qui devrait présenter
d'ici le mois de mai au plus tard donc
si plus que jamais d'actualité
isabelle duclos à guyancourt en 2001 et
créé l'école des parents l'harcèlement
n'est bien sûr j'espère pas au coeur de
toutes les discussions mais est ce que
c'est une problématique qui revient
régulièrement avec les parents alors
régulièrement pour tout vous dire sur
l'année scolaire 2019-2020 celui des
actions individuelles qu'on propose aux
parents qui est la médiation écoles
familles sont maintenant situation on a
eu trois situations dans sont malmenés
et puis sur le des entretiens
individuels avec la psychologue
on a eu sur 55 entretien 8 situation
donc effectivement ce n'est pas un sujet
qui revient régulièrement une
quotidienne mans mais c'est un sujet qui
existe est effectivement il est pris en
compte à d'école des parents à travers
des actions individuelles puisqu ils ont
la possibilité de rencontrer de
médiation école famille très important
sur le lien écoles et parents et enfants
et puis la psychologue puisque l'école
des parents est vraiment là avant touche
vraiment pour accompagner ces familles
leur proposer un espace d'écouté
l'espace montluc
et je suis d'accord avec blandine il
faut pouvoir parler il faut que l'enfant
puisse parler mais le parent 6 et puis
l'espace 207 sensibilisation aux chips
entreposés sac sauver l'équipe
on va voir tout au long de cette
émission d des actions pardon mise en
place par les communes par l'éducation
nationale
il y a aussi le ressenti des français
face aux affaires qui sortent dans les
médias des français qui n'ont pas
nécessairement des proches concernés ou
qui ont connu un phénomène de
harcèlement et chaque semaine nous nous
les interrogeons ces françaises plutôt
nos téléspectateurs saint quentinois et
la question pour cette émission c'était
la lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
et il s'y est elle suffisamment prise au
sérieux les résultats vont s'afficher
c'est la réponse non qui a recueilli le
plus de suffrages
mais au delà des chiffres ce sont aussi
les commentaires sur notre sondage qui
sont marquants il en ressort beaucoup
harcèlement minimiser trop de tolérance
envers les êtres les arts cela est aussi
que ce sont toujours les victimes qui se
voit obligé
quitter l'établissement sébastien
taverne est ce que c'est un ressenti ou
c'est encore des questions sur
lesquelles il faut travailler
je pense très sincèrement que c'est un
ressenti
il faut il faut rappeler que la lutte
contre le harcèlement elle a été
inscrite dans la loi de refondation de
l'école esta depuis depuis 2013 il ya
énormément de choses qui s'en fait aussi
bien en termes de formation que
d'informations que de prévention ce
qu'il en résulte c'est que tant que des
élèves des enfants sont victimes de
harcèlement on n'en fera jamais assez
mais pourtant les actions les actions
demeurent sur le sur le premier
trimestre pour essayer d'être assez à
ses objectifs par rapport aux éléments
le département des yvelines c'est
environ 325 mille élèves répartis
pratiquement équitablement sur le
premier et le second degré au niveau de
la déesse des veines
on suit environ 80 situation de
harcèlement
depuis septembre les faits établissement
qui nous sont remontés le harcèlement
concerne 3 % d'entre eux donc encore une
fois les 3 % sont 3 % trop important
pour les élèves et les familles qui
vivent ces moments là mais je pense pas
qu'on puisse dire que c'est minimiser
depuis quatre ans au niveau de
l'inspection académique des divines
nous avons mis en place une formation
sur tous les collèges tous les lycées et
toutes les circonscriptions pour les
personnels pour les former à prendre en
charge les situations de harcèlement à
les évaluer à les prendre en charge a
accompagné les familles nous formons des
ambassadeurs
tel que blandine et la team non
harcèlement du lycée bascans de
rambouillet aussi bien au lycée quand
collège le coded a quelque peu ralenti
le développement de ces formations-là la
rectrice de versailles à de charline
avenel a souhaité que l'on forme des
ambassadeurs par an ça devait débuter en
janvier février
malheureusement avec le co vie de ces
quelque peu reporter mais ce sont des
choses qui sont aussi mises en place on
informe les parents sont peuvent
retrouver sur sur le site non
harcèlement poinsettia versailles point
fr une plaquette qui a été réalisé pour
leur expliquer qu'ils contactent et
comment être écoutés comment être aidés
et comment prendre en charge en prendre
en charge ceux là enfin sur sur le fait
que ce soient les victimes qui changent
systématiquement en place là aussi je
pense qu'il est important de relativiser
il est parfois nécessaire de déplacer
les victimes de harcèlement ça veut pas
dire que quand on déplace les victimes
on ne s'intéresse plus aux intimidateurs
qui sont qui reste dans l'établissement
il ya des actions qui sont mises en
place de sensibilisation de deux et puis
les réparations éducative aussi qu'ils
peuvent l'être mais il est aussi
important d'expliquer qu' en fonction du
degré du harcèlement on met en place une
méthode s'appelle la méthode pickas qui
est une méthode qui est non de la menthe
et ça c'est parfois mal compris par les
par les parents et les élèves victimes
parce que l'appartement se considère
victime
on attend une réparation et quand on
explique que la méthode pickas travail
sur le développement de l'empathie de ce
qu'on appelle des intimidateurs c'est
parfois compliqué entendre ce que je
comprends tout à fait pour pour les
parents mais non je pense pas qu'on
puisse dire que rien n'est fait et les
chiffres démontrent blandine ferreira
votre rôle d'ambassadeur c'est au sein
de votre établissement avec madame
duclos voulait s'adresser je vous
donnerai la parole juste après blandine
vous allez à la rencontre aussi des plus
jeunes pas seulement des copains
d'établissement à quoi pour peuvent
ressembler vos interventions
alors tout simplement
on sensibilise les 6e mais pas que on
sensibilise les primaires d'ailleurs
précédemment on a été faire une
intervention avec monsieur taverne pour
les cm1 cm2 à l'école victor hugo de
poissy et à quoi ressemble nos
interventions tout simplement une
première partie qui est plutôt théorique
comme un cours magistral où c'est un
échange avec eux pour savoir quelles
qu'elles ont enfin quels sont les
notions qu'ils ont en terme de
harcèlement et le cyber harcèlement et
ensuite ce côté pratique où justement où
fait sous forme de jeu à l'aide d'un
logiciel cloud sous forme de quizz pour
savoir s'ils ont bien compris ce qu'on
leur a expliqué où non et à la fin de
ces deux parties donc ça dure deux
heures on leur donne un questionnaire
pour savoir si justement ils veulent se
confier à nous et on a eu des cas de
harcèlement suite à notre intervention
que ça soit des gros cas où des petits
cas ça partait de simplement vidé son
sac à au suicide
donc nous on n'est pas là pour régler
les problèmes
on est là pour faire l'intermédiaire
entre les adultes et les élèves parce
que les élèves n'ose pas en parler et
c'est quand nous on vient dans
l'établissement qu'ils osent en parler
et que du coup opus faire le relais avec
l'établissement isabelle duclos vous
visez vous souhaitiez parlais tout à
l'heure on peut aussi faire le point que
entre harcèlement et violence il ya
aussi des différences et la première
étape peut-être pour accompagner des
parents oui voilà justement je voulais
rebondir ce que sur ce que disait
monsieur taverne c'est qu'en fait ce qui
est complexe aussi alors que ce soit
pour les parents ou les professionnels
je parle de l'école maternelle et
primaire fait qu'en fait très souvent
l'enfant qui est malmené seul et c'est
vrai on disait qu'on souhaite avant tout
à l'heure qu'il fallait il faire
attention aux mots qu'on en voyait aussi
parce que parfois c'est pas toujours des
situations de harcèlement c'est des
situations d'agressivité c'est des
situations de violence on est malmené et
pas forcément toujours harcelés et en
fait quitté complexe pour la famille et
les enseignants et surtout pour les
familles c'est que souvent l'enfant qui
est malmené l'agresseur sèche entre
camarades
très bon camarade est en fait c'est
toute cette ambivalence pour le parent
ces deux pratiques se rend compte qu'il
voudrait que vite on trouve une solution
voire même on exclut l'agresseur est en
fait c'est plus complexe que ça en fait
ce sont des enfants qui sont capables
par ailleurs on joue ensemble on peut
forcément envie il repris longtemps
malmené se séparer de ce gamin c'est ça
aussi qui rend les choses compliquées et
que chaque situation est vraiment
différente et qui est vraiment
effectivement sur le plan de la douleur
en contre mais on peut vraiment être
étudié chaque situation
oui on parle des harceleurs et personne
n'est prêt disposé à être un jour
arcelor il n'y a pas de profil type
sébastien tavannes comment justement on
sensibilise à cette difficulté de ne pas
passer du côté du harceleur ensemble is
en ne stigmatisant personnes c'est à
dire que le le harcèlement touche tous
types d'écoles collèges ou lycées la
forme évolue en fonction de l'âge on
passe du harcèlement à du
cyberharcèlement et on va former on va
venir sensibiliser dans tous les
établissements
c'est pour ça que je vous le disais tout
à l'heure sur l'échelle du département
des yvelines
à la fin de l'année scolaire tous les
collèges tous les lycées du département
auront des équipes formées à la
prévention et la détection et puis à la
gestion des situations de harcèlement on
développe les ambassadeurs parce que
comme le disait blandine ils ont cette
action d'aller dans les établissements
voire les écoles comme ils l'ont fait à
à poissy lundi matin mais ils ont aussi
des actions développées dans leur propre
établissement pour sensibiliser et puis
pour être identifiés pour pouvoir
discuter être les relais comme l'a très
bien expliqué blandine le rôle d
ambassadeur il est là ces deux
d'expliquer ce que c'est de prévenir et
de leur dire si vous avez un souci
venez de vous en parler nous on pourra
faire le relais auprès des adultes pour
que vous puissiez être entendu et
accompagner que des solutions soient
trouvées
parfois c'est dur de se rapprocher
physiquement d'une personne mais il ya
aussi beaucoup de ressources on les a
vus vite fait l'écran tout à l'heure on
va les revoir il ya des
numéro il y à des sites internet le 30
20 notamment est joignable du lundi au
vendredi de 9 heures à 20 heures jusqu'à
18h le samedi en cas de cyber
harcèlement c'est le 0 800 200 3 0
sébastien théberge et encore à être avec
vous parce qu'il est aussi une adresse
mail qui a été mise en place cette année
elle s'affiche en bas de l'écran quel
est son but
à cette adresse mail le but de l'adresse
mail qu'on a mis en place avec les mes
collègues référent harcèlement sur le
département des yvelines
ces deux d'essayer de facilité pour les
pour les usagers pour les parents mais
aussi pour les professionnels le contact
avec les personnes qui ont en charge le
harcèlement souvent quand on est en
dehors du système du fonctionnement du
système
on écrit à l'inspecteur d'académie ça
arrive à son cabinet et puis ça
transitent par différentes boîtes mail
ça prend un certain temps alors que avec
cette boîte unique
les collègues référence que sont la
conseillère technique à la charnière et
puis assistante sociale et le centre
académique dead aux écoles aux
établissements nous consultons tous
cette boîte quotidiennement ce qui nous
permet de gagner en réactivité en
échange avec les familles alors quand on
parle d'un seul mandat parfois à l'image
des adolescents c'est que ces noeuds
période difficile pour les jeunes on se
renferme sur soi on as encore quelque
chose et tout ça mais selon l'unesco
plus de 30% des élèves dans le monde ont
été victimes de harcèlement et 12% en
école primaire notamment en france
isabelle duclos c'est un public que vous
rencontrez un grand oui tout à fait
c'est le public des écoles primaires
tout à fait sain république et notamment
au niveau de la médiation école famille
puisqu'elle est elle travaille
essentiellement sur ce public là aussi
bien auprès des enseignants et des
familles beaucoup moins auprès des
collèges effectivement le le le
là la tête la thématique de l'enfant à
agresser ou aussi la thématique vous
l'avez du tout à l'heure de l'agresseur
fait partie des situations de médiation
tout à fait et c'est vrai que c'est des
parents qui est trouve dans la médiation
écoles familles la possibilité de
déposer d'être écouté et puis aussi
d'être de redonner une confiance en soi
domestique de soi parce que quand on a
été quand on a un enfant harcelés ou
d'un enfant harceleur et quand des
parents c'est extrêmement compliqué à
vivre c'est extrêmement douloureux et et
voilà de retrouver un de l estime de soi
et de pouvoir trouver un espace neutre
on va pouvoir poser les choses et
trouver ensemble une solution en tout
cas remettre de la communication dans
les dents les relations alors il ya un
autre phénomène lié au harcèlement
scolaire
c'est la dimension que peuvent que
peuvent prendre les réseaux sociaux cela
dépasse le cadre de l'école blandine
ferreira dans un article publié sur le
blog de la team anti-harcèlement c'est
celle de votre établissement vous
sensibiliser aux réseaux sociaux et
notamment les groupes de classe ou
encore dans un autre article sur
l'utilisation de ces mêmes réseaux cd
vidéos pédagogiques vous vous rappelez
le cadre légal et plein de conseils
comment vous les pensez
ces vidéos cesse des retours qu'on vous
fait comme simplement mais on a eu
l'idée parce que pendant le confinement
vous pouvez pas vraiment un père venir
dans les classes donc on a eu cette
continuité pédagogique où justement dont
justement voilà sensibiliser sur le
cyber harcèlement et nous les jeunes on
est très sollicités par rapport aux
réseaux sociaux parce qu'on s'y connaît
on sait quels sont les risques
on sait quelles sont les conséquences et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a fait ces
vidéos là sébastien tavannes dsk les
réseaux sociaux ont été intégrés dans le
programme scolaire peut-être pour plus
sensibilisés maintenant les jeunes ont
accès beaucoup plus facilement que
certains à une autre évoque oui bien
évidemment
on s'adapte aux nouvelles aux nouvelles
technologies il ya des actions qui sont
faites dans les établissements dans les
écoles dans les collèges et lycées sur
la sensibilisation d'une utilisation des
réseaux sociaux
blandine le rappeler c'est des choses
que les jeunes maîtrisent parfaitement
techniquement ils maîtrisent peut-être
un peu moins la porte et quand on envoie
un message quand on envoie une photo
le rival ford fait beaucoup beaucoup de
dégâts il faut en parler il faut
sensibiliser les jeunes hommes et les
jeunes fissures sur ces pratiques là est
donc bien évidemment c'est intégré on on
on sensibilise aussi les parents
d'élèves on en parle peut être pas assez
mais il ya beaucoup d'établissements qui
organise des cafés des parents il ya des
associations d aide à la parentalité qui
sensibilise aussi sur ces questions là
c'est important que les parents aient
conscience aussi que quand leur enfant
est avec son smartphone ou avec sa
tablette ou que sais-je
il peut se passer des choses il faut
pouvoir discuter avec son enfant
vérifier que tout se passe bien mais
sinon dans le cas contraire savoir
trouver les appuis avec les numéros que
vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure avec
les directeurs d'école et chefs
d'établissements les inspecteurs du
premier degré qui seront tous attentifs
aux sollicitations des parents c'est
quelque chose que vous avez inclut aussi
à l'école des parents de peut-être
conseillé à ce que le téléphone ne soit
pas dans la chambre le soir que les
ordinateurs soient coupées qui n'est
peut-être pas de profit sur les réseaux
sociaux un certain âge
ce qui d'ailleurs est interdit selon
l'âge qu'on en a pas besoin d'avoir un
profil sur les réseaux sociaux
oui tout à fait c'est tout à fait des
thèmes copains on peut aborder de façon
individuelle dans le différentes actions
individuelles et différents entretiens
mais aussi au niveau des actions
collectives au delà des réseaux sociaux
il ya effectivement tous les outils qui
peuvent trouver de 2 pour pour être
sensibilisés et nous la sensibilisation
la prévention c'est tout à fait ce qu'on
propose à l'école des parents donc vous
prennent vous parliez du numéro 30 20 et
il ya aussi les petites vidéos qui qu'on
peut trouver sur le site de l'école des
parents
de l'éco dépend de l'éducation nationale
qui s'appelle parents parents parlons-en
cette petite vidéo qui sont très bien
très bien fait ils m'ont a d'ailleurs
pour reprocher ça devait avoir lieu au
mois d'avril
compte tenu des restrictions sanitaires
ça va être décalé et on a pour projet
justement d'organiser une rencontre pour
les parents et les professionnels parce
qu'il me semble que c'est aussi
important quand on les professionnels de
l'éducation
même en dehors de l'éducation nationale
je pense au centre de loisirs
je pense au lieu voilà qui accueillent
ces enfants et qui sont aussi des lieux
des poutres et des changes de proposer
aux professionnels et aux parents la
présentation de ces petites vidéos et
puis derrière d'organiser un débat avec
une écoutante justement une des coups
tordus 30-20 qui va pouvoir justement
pouvoir échanger avec les parents et et
puis l'idée aussi dans tout ça c'est que
les parents puissent repartir avec un
outil parce que nous l'école des parents
on leur propose boîte à outils et et
qu'il puisse repartir avec justement un
numéro de téléphone qui vont pouvoir
rappeler qu'ils puissent avoir en direct
une personne l'écoutante qui va leur
donner des situations et essayer de les
rassurer et puis de les sensibiliser
justement ou harcèlement puisqu'une des
difficultés c'est de détecter votre
enfant est harcelé c'est bien la
difficulté
blandine parler de silence bah oui c'est
ça c'est que on en parle très peu dans
les familles et donc voilà c'est
vraiment ce qu'on a décidé de mettre de
m on va en avant avec le centre social
de la ville parce que le centre social
c'est aussi un lieu où on peut venir
discuter ou iliad est référente famille
et c'est vraiment très important c'est
des lieux neutres et on peut déposer et
poser les choses
justement là on a parlé des effets un
peu pervers des réseaux sociaux ou l'a
vu aussi avec d'autres phénomènes de
société et mis tout le harcèlement
l'inceste parfois les réseaux sociaux
libère la parole sébastien taverne est
ce que vous seriez peut-être un jour
amenés à surveiller les réseaux sociaux
quand on connaît les profils de certains
élèves d'établissements
alors je pense qu'il faut qu'on ce ou
puisse rester dans nos champs de
compétences propres
nous avons de très bons de très bonnes
relations avec les forces de l'ordre
avec la police nationale avec la
gendarmerie sur le département des
yvelines
et quand on a des doutes des inquiétudes
ou qu'eux mêmes repères des choses il ya
un vrai dialogue qui a instauré et à ce
moment là on peut on peut agir
nous notre chambre métier c'est pas de
surveiller les réseaux sociaux c2c de
prévenir des risques qui peut y avoir
sur ceux ci s'est pas dédiaboliser non
plus c'est un outil extraordinaire ça
met du lien ça met de la connaissance
jamais du débat voilà il faut qu'on
qu'on reste vraiment dans nos champs
d'action blandine vous voulez réagir
j'étais un commentaire sur ce qu'a dit
monsieur taggart je trouve que c'est
très intéressant ce qui est l'asie dans
le sens on n'est pas là pour les
diaboliser ça on a le droit d'avoir des
réseaux sociaux c'est pas un crime mais
ça dépend de ce qu'on en fait
l'utilisation
si par exemple on a un compte youtube
pour regarder des vidéos adapté à son
âge il n'y a aucune raison qu'on
interdit les réseaux sociaux si par
exemple la personne est venue facebook
pour juste parlé avec ses amis mes sens
mais elles sont vraies race ouvrage
pardon son vrai prénom sont vraiment
deux femmes il n'y a aucune raison qu'on
lui a interdit les réseaux sociaux et je
vois bien moi dans les établissements un
tout est contrôlé par les parents on a
été à l'école primaire comme je le
disais à poissy tondent avait les trois
quarts des élèves avaient des réseaux
sociaux mais tout était contrôlé par les
parents
donc on va terminer sur ces mots là mais
si je comprends bien il faut ne pas
hésiter à sortir du silence se
rapprocher de professionnels pourquoi
pas les ambassadeurs qui ont souvent
votre âge
durant cette émission nous avons évoqué
à plusieurs reprises les contacts
possibles si vous êtes victimes ou
témoins de harcèlement n'hésitez pas à
vous en rapprocher on les voit encore à
l'écran le 7-8 société est maintenant
terminé merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve nous à la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle demi heure d
ge
où
[Musique]